video games they're an expensive bloody
pastime ah do we get the ball rolling on
this particular hobby you need to jump
$400 on a console a couple of hundred
more on a television Best Buy will
likely charge you $20 for a gold-plated
HDMI cable then $50 you can play with a
friend locally or a subscription to play
with strangers online and if your PC
Gamer you're gonna have to spend closer
to a thousand for a decent rig monitors
mice keyboards a desk a chair oh my
not to mention speakers high-powered
internet and all the mountain dew and
microwave pizzas you can fit in your
fridge and once you have everything
games themselves can cost up to and
Beyond $60 games with features taken out
to be so later as DLC games with season
passes full of extra stuff games that
sometimes don't work or have buggy
servers around anywhere near as fun as
they looked in the trailer Gaming ain't
cheap so it's no wonder we're all so
preoccupied with the dollar amount on
the box it's no wonder Roy's looking up
trailers and previews and reading the
latest industry news gaming more than
any other media requires its fans to arm
themselves with information ahead of the
game's release so that they can make
informed purchasing decisions but
there's a problem with this relationship
it feeds a marketing cycle which is all
but killed the mystery behind games gone
are the days where we don't know
practically everything to do with a
video game before it's launched how it
looks how it plays its feature set
online modes in the DLC rollout plan at
least four big triple-a titles every
once in a while and indeed breakthrough
comes along and we get to play through a
game we don't know all that much about
so perhaps we shouldn't be surprised at
gamers around the world or bulking at
the $60 price tag that's been put on no
man's sky I gained that aside from some
out of context gameplay we really don't
know all that much about so as gamers
how do we resolve our desire to be
surprised with our need to make informed
purchasing decisions today on the point
we ask one question what's the cost of a
mystery
we all have an idea of how much a game
should cost it's subjective we all as
individuals have different incomes
different responsibilities different
economic climates so as individuals we
resolve our own desires with the reality
of our circumstances some of us only buy
games secondhand or on steam sales some
of us treat ourselves to a full-price
game every once in a while some of us
don't have to worry and buy whatever we
want and while inflation has pushed up
the dollar amount on most items and
services games still cost around the
same as when I was born
adjusted for inflation a $50 game in
1986 has now the same buying power as
almost a hundred and ten dollars so the
relative price of games is about half of
what they were three decades ago now
there are economic explanations for why
games cost so little now digital sales
and the compression of retail has
drastically reduced the cost of
distribution sales and physical
advertising while simultaneously opening
up new previously unreachable markets
also there are now more gamers than ever
before so the pot of consumers any one
game can sell to has increased however
there are also plenty of arguments that
say that games shouldn't be this cheap
pointing cost per unit as the reason
that so many mid-tier developers have
crashed over the past decade while large
corporations such as EA Activision and
Ubisoft we're the only ones able to
achieve the requisite economies of scale
to make a $60 price point sustainable
but that economic rabbit hole is only
one side of the equation the other is
psychological what we expect to pay for
something drives consumer
havior and the reality is at the dollar
price on a lot of games those are always
aligned with our own subjective consumer
expectations sell take super hot for
example like getting cost me almost $23
but I completed the campaign in less
than 72 minutes yeah while the witness'
launched its $40 and I could have seemed
pretty expensive but I put well over 25
hours and then I came so far
rocket League on the other hand the game
I got for free on PlayStation Plus I've
easily put over a hundred hours into
since launch so I don't feel bad about
buying literally every piece of DLC did
but everything and I've also talked
about the Destiny conundrum a bunch
again bereft of content for its players
but with a content pipeline that seems
totally reasonable to anyone who spends
as much time with that game as destiny
fans do and while the cost of triple-a
has remained largely stagnant for
decades the pricing around that initial
buy-in is a constantly moving target
last year gamers r up in arms about the
amount of DLC being sold alongside
evolve at launch while this month a year
later we saw the launch of plants vs.
zombies garden warfare - an online
shooter made by EA without a season pass
or launch DLC in sight same for Ubisoft
and Far Cry primal a single-player game
without a season pass or any launch date
DLC dancing around consumer expectations
is what marketing departments are for
and this is why they threat so much
promotional material before game comes
out to poke prospective customers to
gauge expectation this now more than
ever before is the dance that marketers
the media and gamers themselves find
themselves locked in on a day to day
basis but we lost something in this
transaction
mystery the ability to enjoy something
without expectation the ability to be
surprised by what we play every couple
of months there's a breakthrough hitch a
game that was better than anyone was
expecting or a game that the gaming
zeitgeist didn't have any expectations
of at all these games are so much more
enjoyable because we're unlocking their
mysteries ourselves everything feels new
this is why minecraft was such a hit
what made Dark Souls so interesting it's
what I love about playing factorio this
week and that's why it's got such
incredibly high user reviews and though
it's unrealistic to think that every
game
B frog fractions there is something to
be said for attaining mystery do you
think factorial would have sparked so
much interest in gamers if it had a
multi-million dollar advertising
campaign showing off each individual
recipe so to make science PAC one you're
going to want to combine copper plates
with gears now let me tell you the
design decision behind this incredible
new gameplay mechanic and this is the
quandary no man's sky finds itself in we
talked to those guys in the past that
one of the key things I learned was that
they're not interested in explaining
everything about how this game works I'm
happy that they haven't put a trailer
after trailer showing feature sets all
we've seen is snippets of gameplay which
are giving us more questions and answers
and I think that's to be commended by
keeping their cards close to their chest
they're attempting to protect the
mystery around hair this game plays as
consumers this may make us feel
uncomfortable especially when a $60
price tag is introduced but in a world
where we know so much about every single
cookie cutter triple-a release isn't
that just lovely
but somebody out there is doing the hard
work to protect gamers from our rabid
curiosity
I'm at my friend's I'm sad to say is the
final episode of the point or at least
the final episode in this particular
format the reason for this is because
I'm very sad to say but my friend and
creative partner here at GameSpot on so
many projects mr. Andy Bauman the man
behind the camera is leaving GameSpot at
the end of this week
as a lifelong fan of this website I can
say with certainty that his creative eye
has led to some of the best videos this
Web site has ever seen he is
consistently shot and produced high
quality features practically on his own
and I'm incredibly grateful for the time
we had to work together on so many fun
projects the point the new lobby and
features are in games like The Witcher 3
no man's sky
XCOM to World of Warcraft among many
others both of us moved far from where
we grew up for a single mission to make
high quality games coverage that isn't
scared to have fun while asking
difficult questions and I think I speak
for both of us when I say that this show
what it stands for and the amazing
audience we've gathered has been the
single proudest achievement during both
of our times in the industry thank you
all so much for supporting the point and
thank you so much to andy bama for
making a what it is see you around
friends
hey Andy you bring the camera back you
can't have that sorry sorry late again